there's an article i want to read where
the left bemoans republicans are going
to win in order to get to that point we
need to talk about your documentary and
in order to get to that point i do want
to talk about this story about marjorie
taylor green the daily mail incorrectly
reports marjorie taylor greene calls for
national divorce from the east and west
coasts and taxes on californians and new
yorkers moving to different parts of the
country she didn't exactly say that she
said
all possible in a national divorce
scenario after democrat voters and big
donors ruin a state like california you
would think it wise to stop them from
doing it to another great state like
florida brainwashed people that move
from ca to ny really need a cooling off
period now i bring this up not to get
into the nitty-gritty about civil war
national divorce but i want to highlight
and i also stressed she didn't call for
it she she said it was possible totally
absolute headline the reason i wanted to
highlight this is that the idea of
national divorce has become more and
more prominent and i got to be honest
one of the big factors driving why i
think that may be the case
it's not taxes it's not even uh
necessarily democracy i don't know what
else to do well it's the epstein case
it's people literally watching hillary
clinton destroy public records and get
away with it it's people knowing
definitively what was going on with that
island and with maxwell and then it all
getting cover up just after christmas in
russia people are going everything and
russia what are you doing what are you
supposed to not respond to russiagate i
mean are you i mean this is what drives
me nuts are you supposed to not respond
we're supposed to sit here and just
accept the fact that like the entire
national security apparatus of the
united states including the entire media
the entire mainstream media everything i
mean everything every institution that
we have
was working against us and was working
against our president and i obviously i
say this is somebody who was working in
the trump administration but it wasn't
just me it was we were there for
everybody else okay like that was the
whole point it was the hope of america
it was the last hope of normal americans
okay and what we're supposed to we're
supposed to just what are we supposed to
do that's that's the thing we on this
show we try to do you know good segues
you know what i mean so we have we want
to talk about don't look up and the
politics and then you worked in
hollywood and all that and i'm sitting
here thinking like we have these
different paths pathways but when we
started talking about
effectively the cover-up
with what's going on with the maxwell
trial she's guilty haha it's all over
everybody go home records are sealed and
we're like what about bill gates what
about i mean luke's gotta listen les
wexler john luke
kevin spacey bill clinton sorry the most
obvious one of them all like like like
that's the thing is you can you can you
can get caught up in all of the more
detailed ones but you've just got you've
got one that actually like you could go
nuts on bill clinton bill clinton and
look the the left likes to just yell
donald trump because trump right i guess
there's more records that came out i
don't care i don't care you want to
defend trump by all means defend trump i
just want the i want to know what
happened i don't care who's i don't care
who's involved i'm not defending anybody
if someone's involved put out their
files prove it but when i hear this
and and and you're saying you believed
in these institutions it made me think
of this the story that we were going to
get into with the national divorce thing
because i'm like
at a certain point if you have no faith
in the fbi if you have no faith in the
cia if if you think they're actively
working against you and protecting some
of the most despicable and evil people
i gotta say marjorie taylor green in
congress saying a national divorce
scenario is possible i'm like yeah no
it's not for those reasons
it's one of the most mild things you
could say i'm sorry but if you're
supposed to believe we live in that's
why that's why i keep going back to it
we do not live in the country we thought
we did and i i can do nothing but say
that okay i don't have the solution to
that but i i say it over and over again
and people are like yeah okay we don't
live i'm like no no you guys gotta
grapple with what that means that means
the fbi the cia all the institutions
everything it's all gone it's all the
opposite of what it was supposed to be
you might as well be already living in
like a conquered i mean sometimes it
makes people feel uh easier to think
about if you think about a foreign
country right okay we've been taken over
by china fine imagine we've already been
taken over by china that actually is
like totally different completely
different concept we got a story about
that it's probably true okay go go ahead
go ahead no no no we'll get into it
later but mike pompeo said we've been
infiltrated at every level oh so carry
on with your point like i'm like why
would you why would you pick that one
oh man you really went there all right
well because mike pompeo is not my
favorite person that's ever run for
anything um well regardless if yeah of
course he says that of course he says
that you want to know the most obvious
thing on the planet if you ever if you
ever wanted to know the most like
obvious conservative position that was
like the the least hard thing to say
years later than it was actually
important go to mike pompeo pompeo's
twitter and just see what he's saying
like the stuff like where he's like oh
america is not fond of socialists we
will never be a socialist country and
you're like yes thank you sir for saying
that as my friends and i get dragged off
to the gulag i really appreciate you
saying we're not a socialist country
thanks a lot man good good one yeah mike
pompeo was head of the cia caller yeah
let's let's be a little bit careful when
we uh not only that but he not only that
but he was confirmed within three days
okay somebody who's confirmed for the
cia within three days makes me i don't
know if you guys know how the senate
works and all that but that makes me
very uncomfortable number two he put
gina in charge okay gina hospital gina
hospital who i'll remind you was the
head of london station during the
entirety of russia gate okay and you
know what that means and she also has a
bad torturing past as well i don't care
if she tortures like
yes okay fine fine fine fine but look
you cia they're all good at torturing
that's that's where they put these
psychopaths that's why that's why they
that's why they have this these this
place where these weirdos work um but uh
but the but the key here is okay during
russiagate during
all of the durham's
i mean all the stuff that durham is
uncovering uh there is
either she's the most incompetent person
on the planet or she knew every single
thing that was going on in london when
this was happening because at the end of
the day russia gate is not about russia
russia gate is about london all right
and that's something that i think a lot
of us understand i don't know if the
entirety of the country understands that
but russiagate is about london it's
about what happened in london okay and
and and the fact that that person would
be put in charge of art my my
president's cio and i i hate that i hate
to say it well we
i i want to i want to go ahead and do a
full segment on your documentary i
brought up mike pompeo only to mention
that he came out only to drive me nuts
didn't you we're going to talk about it
but
it's i don't care about mike pompeo i
care about the fact that we have a
thousand talent programs uh yeah housing
talents program we have people being
arrested for uh colluding with china
these professors yeah and we have claims
that china has infiltrated the united
states
so yeah and what did he do about it
while we were there i mean do you know
what we had do you know what we had to
do to even get we didn't we couldn't
even get we couldn't even get the higher
ups to say that they were an adversary i
mean i don't know if you guys know how
government works but like trump
administration yeah there's those of us
that like are are in the uh middle ranks
the lower ranks whatever you want to
call it i have no i have no like like
like uh uh
pretense about like where i worked or
whatever i mean i was at das at one
point who cares well so none of this
matters but my question is you know we
had to do to even get that
to get that no to get to to get to okay
so the language that's used at state
department is very very important this
actually
uh categorizes countries in a different
category than they would normally be and
there's things there's there's all kinds
of levels there's adversary there's
there's a
challenge there's um
enemy there's well i mean i'm sorry i'm
probably listing them wrong but
the idea that mike pompeo was actually
properly uh uh uh tough on china and i
don't know iran is absolutely nonsense i
do want to i want to
have a full segment sure sure yeah and
so i'm i'm more curious as to whether
you think china has infiltrated the
united states and it's something oh
absolutely i mean there's no i'm sorry i
didn't even think there was a question
about that i'm so sorry yes of course
absolutely i mean you've got you've got
we're not even trying we're not even
looking at our universities we're not
like we can't even have certain forums
we can't even have conferences uh uh uh
uh about certain issues because so many
foreign countries own our universities
which i don't care about the universe i
mean i do care about the universities
but they also uh control the think tanks
they control the
conferences they control all of this
stuff that's happening we could barely
do a conference that was uh
semi-accurate about uh
cutter okay and this was a very very big
deal that happened in dc while i was
working there and and and there were
people that i actually quite like that
were like uh i can't go to that because
i'm sponsored by a university that does
x y and z and it turns out that's who's
paying for everything and uh you know
okay times that by 2 000 for china okay
forget forget qatar china
has the entire i mean are there i i i
can think of almost i can think of like
one or two
foreign policy institutes in the united
states that are actually
free to express themselves and free to
uh
to argue the points that are actually
for the united states that's how bad it
is i mean they've taken over from the
inside for a long long time and it's not
just the you know confucius institutes
and all that which i'm i'm assuming you
know well about all that okay so okay
we're talking about like when you own
the universities it's not just about
owning the universities you own the
thought process that comes out of that
because that's how our nation's built
right we're built on think tanks and uh
and white papers and x y and z and then
these are the people that are hired in
the higher uh levels of the institutions
like the state department and whatnot
which end up becoming the people that
make the decisions that decide what's
going to happen in our foreign policy
it's not nothing it's not just
white papers and uh and and and
arguments and and conferences and and
fluffy things like that
these are these are the people that are
going to actually sign the papers
they're going to make the decisions
they're going to decide what the un
statement says et cetera et cetera et
cetera it's it could not be more
significant and uh
there were others that saw this besides
me okay it's not just me it's just that
uh we're quite outnumbered i mean like
it's it's it's not easy to to shout this
stuff from the rooftop because you just
you they they write you off as a loon
and thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you